これで全部か
うわー
こうしてみると凄い実感する
今からやることを
さてとやりますか
僕は
今から
遊戯王カード全部売ります❗️
デッキは除く
デッキは除きます
遊戯王はやめません
絶対やめません
やめないですけれども
さすがにこの量を見てもらうとわかるんですけれど
カードが多すぎるんですよ
一時間、二時間じゃ見きれないレベルのカードの量になっていて
カードを見るのに
一日とか時間取られると
さすがにやばいと思いまして
もっと時間を有効に活用するためにも
僕が今後、スムーズに遊戯王カードを楽しむためにも
一回ここのカード、全部売ります❗️
え？
それも？
うん
嘘だ
ねぇ、やめてよ
僕こっそりね、いろんなカードを未開封で採ってあるんですよ
こういう
本当にね、
マジで涙が出そうです
あのお金だけで集めてきたわけじゃないんですよ
時間もかけていろんなショップに友達とかと回って
ちよっとほんとに泣けてきた
あのぅ
二年間ぐらいずっとね、いろんな人たちと
集めてきたカードなんです
いろんなカードを探し回って集めてきたカードなんですけど
まあ断捨離というか、一回全部売ります
デッキ売っちゃだめだよね
泣いてんの
泣いてないよ
はは！
よしやろう
みんなとの思い出も捨てるんだよ
いや、心に残っているからいいよ
はい、という訳で売っていく方法なんですけども、
お店にカードリストと言うものが有ります。
カードが何円で売れるか全部書いてあります。
こういう感じでね、一枚当たりの値段が書いてあるので、
この表にチェックをつけながら、レアカードを今から集めてって、
まずは、レアカードを全部売って、何円になるかを調べます。
こんなね、光ってもないカードが、50円で売れますよ
この時点でもう200円です
あー、なるほど、翌日とかでも大丈夫ってことですか？
あっ、なるほど、わかりました
一枚ずつ見ていると、本当に時間がないので、
カードリストに載っているレアカードだけ、ピックアップして
ある店に送ります。
残りはそのまままとめてみてくれるお店があるので
チェックなしのところは店に全部渡して
合算した値段が今回の売値になります。
アルティマヤ・ツィオルキン、1000円です。
700円
怖いよ、遊戯王カード
遊戯王カード全部売ります。
ねー、やめなよ～
えーもったいないよ～
ほら、もぉーっ全く同じはずの
だめだよー
やめてよーっ！！
カイザーシースネーク、800円でございます
神の通告、1200円です
ギャラクシーアイズ・サイファー・ドラゴン（銀河眼の光波流）、1000円です
聖なるバリアミラーフォース！
聖バリあった
お！問わず10円だって
うっわ！
「アロマージ」このタイミングできたよ
えっ！？アローマージはやばい
アはやばい
ここでアが来るか・・・。
血色がでそう
ツインツイスター、1枚700円です
5枚あるので、これで3500円です
でたよ、DDクロー
今流行の
流行ってるの？
流行ってる
烈火王テムジン、1800円です
ティマイオスの眼、1500円
ギャラクシーアイズ・プライム・フォトン（銀河眼の光子竜皇）、1300円です
ギャラクシーアイズ・タキオン・ドラゴン（銀河眼の時空竜）、1200円
8時間半、遊戯王カードずっと触っております
ファントム・ナイツブレイクソード（幻影騎士団ブレイクソード）、1000円
白夜のグラディウス、1800円
2枚あるので、これで3600円です
3000円・・・。
1枚？！
×5だから、15000！
怖え～
ブラック・マジシャン・ガール、3000円
多分これが一番高いです
5枚なので
15000円です
ブルーアイズ・オルタナティブ・ドラゴン（青眼の亜白龍）、2200円です
フレシアの蟲惑魔、1200円
ラーの翼神竜－球体形、1100円です
レアカード、終了でございます
わかる？レアカード見るだけでも11時間半かかるから
もし俺がこれノーマルカードを何か探そうかとってみたら
もう1日どころじゃないんですよ
これが全部ノーマルカード
で、こっちにレアカードをまとめて
でこれはさっき見てたカードチップリストですね
あそこに書いてあった本当に高いカードです
本当にもう僕にはあと戦うためのデッキしか残っていません
早速、行ってきましょう！
果たして、何円になるのでしょうか？
どんぐらいだと思う？
100まn
はい、というわけで1件目のショップにつきました
こちらではガチのレアカードじゃない方のカードだけを売ってきます
ちゃんとどれが高いのかをメモしておきました
買い取りなんとか渡すことはできたんですけども
ちょっと時間がかかるみたいで
今お昼なんですけど
夜の10時位まで時間がかかりそうということなので
もう1店舗行こう！
こちらではさっきのチェックリストに入れた
高いカードのみをチェックリストに入れた
もう、高級カードだけを売りに行きます
では、行ってきます
えーと、話によると
30分から1時間位だと
チェックリストがあるから早いんだよ
飯食おう
行ってきます
逆にまだかかりそうですね
一回解散かな、これは
多分電話くれるって言ってくれたから
夜中にもう一回くればいいか
はい、というわけで査定がまだまだ時間かかりそうだったので
多分、終わるのは夜中になりそうです
なので夜中まで・・・
休憩！